allez qui a dit comme j'ai jamais été
perçu comme une femme glamour j'ai
l'impression de moins vieillir dans mon
métier allez une idée Sophie
c'est une Française posez-moi des
questions sur elle c'est une comédienne
oui
c'est aussi une comédienne de télé elle
fait des one man show
[Applaudissements]
bravo
bravo elle fait surtout de la télé alors
selon l'actrice comédienne humoriste la
vision de la femme dans le milieu du
divertissement et je voudrais connaître
votre avis et peu encourageante l'image
de la femme dans le milieu du showbiz au
point que ces rondeurs l'arrangeraient
et seraient même une chance d'y tel je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez ah oui il
y a pas de ronde ici quand on est très
très rond ou très
[Rires]
courtois
dans le sens où quand on mise tout sur
son physique une fois que les années
passent et que la beauté était faite on
a plus rien sur quoi miser après alors
que tandis qu'on a quand on allume
l'humour on a d'autres choses la finesse
d'esprit là là on peut le dire on peut
avoir les deux et puis c'est un amour
attends Ludivine ronde oui je suis un
petit en surpoids enfin j'ai des formes
par exemple ah non je me vois pas je
m'imaginerai pas maigre du tout je l'ai
déjà été ça me va pas mais bon au-delà
de tout parler de mon corps
totalement charmante appétit
bien sûr mais moi je suis à la préfère
non mais au-delà de ça moi je crois que
c'est une très bonne cartouche
généralement quand on est justement moi
j'en fais partie d'un des personnes un
peu en surpoids comme Amel Bent à
l'époque on aime bien dire ah ouais moi
j'adore mes formes j'adore mes courbes
mais dès qu'on trouve un régime oui
alors on court si on goût frais donc en
vrai on a envie de faire partie un petit
peu des critères en revanche je trouve
ça un petit peu un petit peu pas mal
honnête mais elle a jamais été perçue
comme une femme glamour Michel Bernier
parce que elle peut-être pouvait pas
prétendre à être une femme glamour avec
les dictats non plus de l'épaisseur
alors moi je suis pas d'accord
entre parce que toi tu es considéré
comme une très belle femme elle ce
qu'elle dit c'est qu'elle n'a jamais été
considéré comme une belle femme du coup
ça lui épargne dans les magazines les
phrases du style encore belle toujours
belle ou qu'est-ce qu'elle s'est fait
faire elle est comme elle est elle a
jamais cherché à être autre chose cela
dit il est très grande mètre carré
à vouloir être mince et bien je ne serai
jamais aujourd'hui j'ai juste une limite
de poids ne pas dépasser car je sais
qu'au-delà je me sens pas bien c'est ça
qui est essentiel le tout dans la vie
c'est de sentir bien ou pas rond c'est
de s'accepter ça a l'air cliché mais
c'est mais d'abord
20 ans ils avaient 95 c'était le petit
gros de la télé grande asperges aussi on
disait tout le temps ouais mais il fait
100 kg et il fait 1m95 parce qu'elle
sait tu vois c'est une bête
j'ai toujours accepté ce rôle et
d'entendre les gens me dire gentiment à
le rond de la télé mais c'est lequel
c'est le gros ou le grand
ça m'énerve pas parce que sinon je ferai
des régimes etc mais je fais attention
pour ma santé et voilà parce que j'ai 60
balais qu'il faut arrêter les conneries
mais oui c'est un petit combat tout le
temps honteux de vouloir être plus mince
ou d'avoir envie de maigrir non le tout
c'est d'être bien dans sa peau c'est
l'essentiel que tu sois rond maigre ou
machin Florian Michel Bernier elle en a
souffert quand même et notamment à
l'époque où il était avec Bruno gasciaux
Bruno Gaso a même plus lui-même la
défendre publiquement je me souviens de
d'interview dans des dans plusieurs
émissions où il prenait sa défense après
qu'elle a été moquée par certains
animateurs notamment à ses connus donc
certes ça lui a pas joué des tours dans
sa carrière comme Mimie Mathy avec qui
est la démarrer parce qu'elles avaient
démarré ensemble un autre créateur donc
mais dans sa vie personnelle ça a été
plus compliqué Francesca moi simplement
pour pour être honnête j'ai l'impression
que peu importe comment on est qu'on
soit rond qu'on soit très mince on s'en
prend toujours plein la gueule et on
n'est jamais comme il faut 30 kilos
je me fais défoncer sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que oui je suis trop
maigre mange tout ça enfin c'est hyper
dur aussi dans un autre sens et les gens
ils connaissent pas ta vie ils se
permettent d'être hyper méchant donc je
trouve ça jamais agréable et moi je dis
vous diriez pas ça à quelqu'un de rond
parce qu'on doit être soumis à la
critique
c'est un métier d'image ce serait
compliqué je me surveille pas moi mon
âge tu as toujours été à peu près pareil
parce que le pire aussi c'est comme ça
tu as dû prendre un tout petit peu de
poids parce que tu vieillis tu fais
attention bah oui
[Rires]
toujours eu la même silhouette
tu avais la coupe mulet par contre j'ai
jamais eu la copuler un petit peu
j'avais la coupe Julio Iglesias
les années 80-90 ça va pas de recherche
sur
le dit elle a toujours une des rôles de
séductrice Michel je l'adore c'est une
très grande actrice c'est un amour de
femme croyez-moi c'est un amour de femme
j'adore cette femme là Sophie tu voulais
rajouter quelque chose je vous entends
parler de tout le monde est beau tout le
monde est super et non tout le monde est
pas bon c'est vrai que vous vous avez un
métabolisme qui est facile vous avez
passé
vous avez plus 60 ans et vous avez pas
de variation moi j'ai un métabolisme
facile franchement hyper facile donc
c'est vrai que voilà bah oui c'est la
beauté intérieure bah ok mais quand on a
la chance de pouvoir bouffer ce qu'on
veut de pas perdre de pas prendre un
drame
j'ai cherché
elle veut dire
[Rires]
c'est dramatique
bon appétit bon appétit
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]